hello everyone welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the 1914
tournament of sank Peter Berg and so
glad that a lot of you have caught this
eye I didn't mention it in the previous
video as I was too busy seeing who's who
and what great quality the photos were
but yeah in this photo you can see how
Capablanca is really giving Alaska the
look and also not just in this photo but
if you look at this photo it's really
like you're going down and I don't know
if I've heard somewhere that in the
really old photos where the eyes weren't
really caught or they were just you know
the blurry or something that they would
later redo the eyes so maybe maybe
capablanca isn't actually giving law
school to stare maybe it was added
afterwards but if not he really does
seem to be doing it and yeah okay Frank
James Marshall is definitely looking at
at the photographer and Ally him looking
at some something in the back but Blanca
definitely giving Lasker the stare but
okay yeah in this game Jose Rosa Blanca
this is the second round of the 1914 son
Peter Burke tournament faces his old
rival Frank James Marshall who is well
one of the people that is mostly to
thank that cover blanca was even able to
play in the 1911 son Sebastian
tournament and that his career took such
a huge sudden leap if you remember he
had a couple Blanco defeated Frank James
Marshall in a match be a prior to the
1911 son Sebastian tournament which
eight wins and only one loss and during
the san sebastian tournament we skipped
the game it was a really short to draw I
just started the opening so very
interested to see how this game will
turn out like we said couple Lanka has
the white pieces and he opens with E 4
we have E 5 Knight to f3 and Knight to
f6 the better defense and if you've seen
the previous video we mentioned that
Capablanca spoke very highly of Paul
Morphy and that he said that
Morpheus ideas would white against the
petrov are still considered in those
days by Capablanca and Lasker
to be the best continuation for white so
nice captures on e5 this is the
classical variation and it's still being
played today capablanca sorta a phobia
no Corwin I employed it very nicely with
the black pieces we have these six night
back to f3 and now Knight captures on e4
with d4 and now black wastes a tempo as
he already played these six with d5 but
it doesn't really matter as a white
already played with the knight Knight
captures on e5 and Knight back to f3 so
it's not really that that big of a waste
of a time Bishop to b3 and now Bishop to
d6 and here today well you will most
likely see castling here but then
capablanca played c4 and here black
could continue in a various ways you
could play c6 e with castle but this
early c4 idea leaves open an opportunity
for for Frank Marshall to play this
Bishop to b4 check and with his knights
being on e4 this allows him to exchange
a fairly a lot of pieces which
Capablanca doesn't mind
capablanca always you know welcomes
trade trading pieces and going straight
into the endgame but here it's mostly
favors black and it really just
oversimplifies the position for black we
have Knight B to d2
of course you cannot go Knight to c3
just loses pretty much instantly as you
would lose the exchange here Rob okay
Knight B to d2 and now we have castles
by Marshall I with castle by capablanca
and now Knight captures on d2 here
friend James Marshall is able to
exchange a few of the pieces Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Knight
to c6 doesn't bother himself with this
c6 move and here rook F to e 1 here if
Capablanca wants he could play a closed
position with c5 but he chooses a rook
to e1 with Bishop to g4 now threatening
to capture on f3 and now Knight goes to
e5 there is still no threat of Knight
captures on d4 as the bishop characters
on h7 is always an idea
so Knights the five attacking the bishop
on g4 and now Knight captures on e5
rook captures on e5 and now comes D
captures on c4 the
captures on c4 and now Queen to f6 now
that with the idea of bringing to the
district over to the H the pressure the
d4 pawn
so first rook 81 kappa blanka now
doubles up rooks on the e-file and now
if you look at this position the
material on the board is equal there is
a small difference marshal has only two
points capablanca has three point
islands and the exception is he has an
isolated D pawn which can be a weakness
but it can also be a strength to defend
depends on how you play a player game
first rook a to d8 now both the Queen
and the rook are pressuring the d4 pawn
it seems that the rook on e5 cannot move
but Capablanca finds a very nice way to
move it not the the most precise way to
continue playing this but definitely the
most interesting way rook to e7 here a
couple Blanca offers the d4 pawn and
indeed if you captured it with the rook
then white can win the game instantly
it's a very nice tactic so feel free to
pause the video and try to find what
capablanca had in mind here I'll give
you a couple of seconds as usual for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are excellent winner
of games and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show the movies rook
captures on f7 and now you can see that
black white is threatening all sorts of
discoveries with the bishop on c4 eyeing
that King and g8 if you capture the
bishop then of course you lose the Queen
and if you capture the Queen then you
get a rogue chapters on f6 with check
there is nothing black can use to
eliminate the bishop on c4 which is the
piece that gives the check you can give
up a few of the pieces before our
resigning completely but the game will
end after King h8 and rook captures on
my fate this will be checkmate so this
is a the general idea on the other hand
if you capture with the Queen this is
possible but then the Queen captures
rook captures and again you get rook
captures on c7 where you would have at
the exact same material on the board
white would have some lead in
development but still overall a better
position for white hard to save if you
could actually push for anything here
most likely not but okay Marshall finds
a different idea he plays Bishop to e6
prevents any ideas Capablanca had of
capturing on f7 and also he traps copper
Blancas rook here and now this was
couple
Langer's idea rook captures on e6 with F
captures on e6 and now the other row
captures on e6 so why did Marshall allow
this his queen is under attack after he
moves the Queen he will be treated to
all sorts of nasty discoveries after the
rook moves as the bishop is once again
x-raying the king and GA so what was his
plan here it's interesting if you play
something like Queen to f7 seems like a
reasonable move if the rook moves then
you simply grab the bishop on c4 but
then white has this rook to c6 move or
opening up a discovered attack and also
defending the bishop and here black
would have to go for beat captures on c6
and after a white grabs the Queen rook
captures on f7 we would have a queen
against two rooks and after Queen c3 we
would have look F D d7 going after the
d4 pawn Queen captures rook captures and
then after g3 defending against any
background weaknesses you would have
this endgame where white is a queen
against the two looks and up a pawn and
the two pawns are very easy targets for
the White Queen so white would
definitely have the advantage here but
Marshall has a different plan he played
the queen capture some d4 and this is
the best way to go about it now you
can't do any discoveries now rook the c6
check doesn't really do anything because
of Queen captures on c4 you just grab
the bishop and you don't mind this rook
captures because the real capture screen
and then black is just up a whole rook
so after this Queen to d4 kappa blanka
found Queen to d6 block the rooks attack
towards the Queen on d2 and also there
is a discovered check now so what do you
do here we have Queen captures on c4 by
marshal and now comes rogue captures on
d8 rook captures on d8 Queen captures
and e8
with Czech and now Queen to f7
Capablanca plays Queen to d7 check and
here we have King to f6 marshal could go
back and up for some repetition of moves
but the marshal still wants to play this
game King to f6 and now we have g4
Capablanca offers the a to pawn the
perhaps trap trap the a martial skin gun
f6 and oh maybe he's hoping he can go
maybe some h4
five ideas and see what happens and
Marshall calculates precisely he grabs
the a to pawn and it doesn't see a wake
up a Blanca can win this we have Queen
to d8 by Capablanca not grabbing the C
seven point immediately first he wants
Marshall to go back and then he wants to
capture the pawn with check but Marshall
goes all the way to g6 we have Queen to
d3 check now for forcing the King back
if you try something like King to h6
there's still not a lot of white can do
to trap the King but you don't want to
law something like h4 your King would
feel very uncomfortable they're soaking
back to f7 and now we have Queen to f3
check now capablanca connected to check
and we'll grab the b7 pawn which will
also protect the B to pawn we have
kinked East 7 Queen captures on b7 now
protecting the pawn and now Queen to c4
here Marshall defends this c7 pawn and
also threatens to capture the g4 pawn
with check so couple UNK a defense that
we have h3 and now King to d6 we have b3
now attacking Marshalls Queen Queen to
d4 now this pawn is defended at this
point is defended by the Queen
everything is defended and Queen to a6
check by Capablanca we have c6 and now
pointing to b7 pressuring the King side
pawns even for the time being all of the
pawns are defended we have a 5 by
Marshall pushing his passport but also
limiting the mobility of whites b-pawn
we have Queen to b8 check King to d7 and
here couple Blanco repeated Queen - b7
check with King to d6 Queen to be a
check and King to d7 and it was in this
position I'll move 35 that josé raúl
capablanca and Frank James Marshall
agreed to a draw so as you can see after
that match against Frank James Marshall
which Capablanca won 8 to 1 but if you
remember if you were following the saga
from the beginning you know that a cup
of Monica was leading 7 to 1 and then
you had a series of I believe 10 draws
or maybe not 10 but a huge series of
drawers before Capablanca eventually won
the last game and got the result 8 to 1
then they again met in the 1911 census
tournament where they also made a
quick-draw and here it wasn't a
quick-draw 35 Musa and the fighting draw
both players tried a lot but in the end
you know it's always nice to see to see
a fighting draw but yeah that's around
two of the 1914 Sun picture-book chess
tournament like we said we have a single
round-robin where all of the players
will compete if you if you haven't seen
the previous video here are all the
players that will compete here and then
five of the players that do best will
continue in the second part of the
tournament where five of them will go
into a double round-robin to see who is
the true champion yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I decided not to
skip it even though it's a draw I know
some of you don't like draws but we
already skipped the game against
Marshall in the san sebastian tournament
so I decided to show this one as it
wasn't just like a draw out of the
opening so and it's also a nice piece of
history as you know couple one can
marshal really do have a long history
yeah yeah and I do hope you're enjoying
the couple Blanco saga so far I would
like to thank Mario and Somoza
Tony Clements Aviva Ghandi Matt Matt
Edwards and Alan black for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content most likely
continuing the capablanca saga as it
really is a vast saga so i think i'll
and i will see you soon